hello everybody i am delighted to be
here with father maximus konstas father
maximus is really uh one of the world's
most renowned scholars on st maximus the
confessor of whom i talk about a lot on
this channel hopefully even
non-orthodox people by now will know who
that is and how important he is he is
has translated many of uh saint
maxwell's work he's also written his own
book
in particular the art of seeing which is
a
powerful look at icons and so he has
this interest in chatristics in the
scholarly work but also in art which is
why it seems like our stars were meant
to align at some point and we get to
this discussion
um he is right now he's a professor of
patristics and orthodox spirituality
at a holy cross seminary
he was a professor at harvard he was a
monk for many years at simon petra on
the holy mountain
he's the director of the pappas
patristic institute right now and so as
you see he is someone who not only is a
scholar but is also a
a a monk and a spiritual practicer and
so i'm really excited to be able to talk
about uh say maximus and also about art
and about how these two things come
together to help us understand the world
today
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
and so uh father maximus thank you so
much for taking the time to talk to me
today
sure thanks for having me it's a
pleasure to be here
and so uh
my first question is
you have become the one of the world's
most renowned scholars on saint maximus
of course you
come at it as an academic but also
you made these discoveries as a priest
and a monk
i would like to hear a little bit about
your journey and how the work of say
maximus informed your academic career
but also your own spiritual path your
own spiritual discoveries
yeah i mean i should say that there are
many people uh in north america and
western europe and in other places
who have distinguished themselves
as uh really great scholars of uh saint
maximus the confessor i may or may not
be one of them but there are many people
who deserve that kind of uh praise
uh he is a complex thinker and writer as
you know and uh
it takes a a a group of people to
approach them from different
perspectives to you know really begin to
get at all the issues there so one
person can't do it alone so hopefully
scholars work together as a team as part
of a community and we do what we do
um
my sort of doctoral work was in uh
futuristics
so this kind of a natural fit there
though my initial studies were on the
kind of classical christological
controversy of the fifth century and it
wasn't until some years later that i
became a monk and received the name of
maximus
after maximus the confessor that
i became increasingly curious about my
new sort of patron saint
and uh so i began to read uh because
years ago
it was very little that was available in
english and uh i never had a course on
maximus the confessor so he was
for me anyway somewhat you know
uncharted or unknown uh territory
then i received an invitation from uh
dunbar oaks which had just launched a
new
uh
text and translation series known as the
dumbarton oaks medieval library and if
you're
your viewers are interested in
uh
some patristic and byzantine texts
there's
a growing number of volumes there that
they would find to be of uh interest so
i had an opportunity to contribute
something to the series and i decided i
would
choose a work by saint maximus that
wasn't
available in english
and i
chose the ambiguous
of course i found out
after that that the greek text needed to
be edited and all of that so i'm not
going to get into those details right
now
but uh the book was completed and
finished in uh 2014
and uh it's it's in two volumes in that
series and uh if i can toot my own horn
a little bit
uh they tell me that it's it's it's
consistently been the number one best
seller in uh
the byzantines here with dumbarton yeah
so that sold an incredible number of
units so in case anybody's
jealous or envious i don't get any
royalties so
so uh the other part of though the other
thing that's worth mentioning maybe is
that
this was a project that i began and
completed you know at the monastery
and it it'll forever be a part of that
experience for me because
i think
undertaking and trying to complete
a project like that outside the
monastery for me anyway would have been
much more challenging and maybe even
impossible i mean the monastery provides
you
not only with the
stability
and the routine without you know
significant disruptions and
interruptions but you also have
a particular
focus or clarity or
quality of mind
that is hard to find outside of that uh
environment i mean
you forget what that quality of mind is
or what that clarity of mind is and then
you then you need to remember you forget
to even remember to so you have to
remember to remember what
it is that you are or who you are
so i think it was really a gift of the
monastery that
enabled me to engage all of the
complexities of his language and uh
concepts because i often look back on
that project and i sometimes wonder how
i was able to do it because
i live in boston now and i teach and
it's just a different world and
your
energy and attention is just a very
different thing so
yeah because i i if i understand
correctly when you started translating
the ambiguous you had never fully read
it before like you really kind of dived
in
all
feet first let's say
i mean it's a lengthy word and it was
available only in greek and uh it's very
difficult to read so you start at the
beginning and you just don't get very
far
um without a translation or a better
text and uh so it was it was a voyage of
discovery definitely i mean it was sort
of a because i was not familiar with the
text
it often felt like there was a
revelation on every page
it was all new to me at the time so
that's amazing and you didn't you didn't
mention but you did have to do yourself
collating some of the greek texts
themselves you had to find
these different manuscripts and texts
and try to read
that to find the best version or to
bring about a good version of the greek
itself
yeah i i going into it i thought it was
going to be a quote easy translation
project and then i found out that the
text was in just terrible shape
the only the the greek text that we had
published in the standard greek
petrology
was just riddled with errors
in places it was saying the opposite of
what you know saint max has written so
uh fortunately i had the training
for my doctoral studies and i had to
round up
uh the actual manuscripts
and collate them and and uh establish
you know a better addition of the text
which is what you see in the
volume so it was it was a big project it
took three years
but uh i enjoyed every minute of it um
and so like i mentioned at the beginning
we both have
several things in common of course one
is a love of a maximus me let's say as
an amateur um but also we have uh both
have a love of liturgical art and icons
in particular and there is a deep
connection between the two in works uh
like the mystic where say maximus
creates this strict analogical
relationship between a human person and
the actual architecture of the church
the church building
and this is of course in line with how
my house maximus creates this microcosm
macrocosm relationship all through his
writing and so could you help us
understand a little more how sam maximus
does this how he links the visible to
the invisible the architecture to the
body uh these types of relationships in
his work
yeah um
i don't know if unfortunately it's the
right adverb to to begin with but this
is a when you're dealing with anything
in
maximus the confessor always tends
toward kind of a thorny complexity
so uh there's always multiple steps you
kind of have to negotiate and uh i think
the first thing to say is that there's
definitely what you would call
a sort of aesthetic dimension
to his writing and to his worldview i
mean he sees creation
as a theophany
as a literal manifestation of the divine
so how could this be devoid of something
that could be fairly called you know an
aesthetic
but the problem is is that that
aesthetic so-called is really part of a
much
larger phenomenon and it would really be
reductive to
uh isolate it from
uh that larger let's just call it
phenomenon right now i mean
it would be like separating the body
from the soul or
sensation from intellection and focusing
just on one dimension of this larger
kind of organic uh a whole
i think something similar happens when
people identify saint maximus as a
philosopher
and there's definitely a philosophical
side to him but to reduce him to that i
think is to impoverish
all the other things that uh make him uh
who he is now it's intellectually very
respectable to say you're studying a
late ancient philosopher but
it's not really an accurate
representation of who he was or what he
did so again so aesthetics just should
not be
abstracted from this kind of larger
metaphysical and cosmological uh fabric
i mean there's also a liturgical fabric
that's part of this too so it really
needs to be seen in these
in this larger kind of uh
atmosphere or
uh environment but but the question
though is really interesting because the
relationship between the visible and the
invisible it's a very old kind of
question or problem
finds an interesting development or
clarification in uh maximus and this is
important i think because many people
think that christianity is some kind of
dualistic religion or that it's somehow
hostile to matter or hostile to the body
or things like that now i mean that
might be true of some christian
traditions i don't know but i think it's
very difficult to level such a charge
against orthodox christianity or
or against uh maximus in this particular
case i mean it's true and obvious i
think that the greek fathers made use of
the platonic uh tradition which is why
they often get implicated in this charge
of dualism but the platonic tradition
was not nearly as dualistic as most
people uh imagined i mean for the first
thing you have you have sort of the
early platonic dialogues which do tend
toward a greater degree of dualism but
the later platonic dialogues the times
and so forth move in the direction of a
very different construal
of let's say the physical and uh the
spiritual and by the time you get to a
writer like platinus is kind of the
so-called father of neoplatonism he's
writing about 300 years or so after
plato platinus i mean is so far beyond
any kind of platonic uh dualism that he
consistently avoids
plato's spatial
categories of above and below for
example the the forms are above and
they're reflected sort of in this lower
world and he really avoids that kind of
language and he replaces it with
words and concepts that begin with this
the greek
uh uh uh
uh preposition prefix scene like simpson
or synthesis or synergy or synoptic or
synaptic right this is a this is a
part of speech that unifies things so
platinus likes doesn't like to see
things separate he likes to see them
coupled in some way i mean united or
unified
in some form because he he himself sees
the unity in all things and this is the
way his sort of philosophy unfolds not
as a kind of you know disjunction of the
spiritual and the physical but they're
on a kind of a continuum and i couldn't
tell you where exactly somewhere in the
amiads
he makes this great quote where he says
sensations here and by here he means in
this life in this world
sensations here
are dim intellections
but intellections there he means in the
spiritual world are vivid sensations
so they're on this kind of continuum
and they're they're sort of the same
thing but just in different places and
therefore they have different uh sort of
valences
now i mean here's where we can here's
what we need to locate maximus i mean in
this later neoplatonic tradition that is
decidedly not dualistic at all but uh uh
embracing this kind of formula or model
of
uh unity and this is we see maximus
everywhere interested
in uh
the immediacy of things and the kind of
you know mutual
presence of things to one another and
even a kind of mutual interiority that
things have uh to each other not their
opposition whether it's spatially
construed or uh
otherwise
and
this is this makes sense because he was
partly reacting to the originist
tradition which was more dualistically
platonic uh in that sense that i just
described and there was no real
difference there because in the kind of
gnostic ascent of the mind you know back
toward the one i mean differences would
fall away so gender would fall away and
the body would fall away individuality
would fall away and there would be this
return to a kind of you know homogeneous
collective state in which there was no
person or individual and of course
maximus is pushing back against this so
he comes down hard on
uh
particularity here but you know within
this kind of uh union so
i think the key here maybe is is the is
the
christological teaching of the council
of calcium that many people are familiar
with because it's the position that
christ's two natures are related to one
another through these famous four
adverbs that the two natures are neither
confused or altered
so that means they retain their
integrity
one is not
elided with the other or confused or
conflated with the other so they're
without confusion and they're without
change but they're also they also
coexist inseparably
uh and uh undivided indivisibly
so it's sort of like wanting it both
ways that they're totally one but
they're also at the same time totally uh
distinct i think that becomes his
christological model for this unity
without uh
confusion
among the constituent elements of
whatever it is the body the world the
church you name it so
and it's what's interesting at least to
me in his in his theory his approach is
that you can really apply it fractally
at almost all levels of reality and it
it actually becomes like a theory of
becomes a theory of reality which is
even today people are noticing the
problem let's say of unity and
multiplicity but same access really
offers this capacity for things to both
exist
to a certain manner as one but also
without containing their multiple
elements at the level at which those
multiple elements are real but that this
doesn't prevent them from joining up
together and so it creates like this
this massive movement where all things
can both exist at the level they exist
but are united to their different
purposes coming together up all the way
into into christ and into god himself
right i think it's funny because i think
in our
world
at least nowadays we're trying to sort
that question out politically
and that may or may not be the best
place to do it but we have our own
version of this
dilemma let's say not in terms of
metaphysics and the one and the many and
so forth but in terms of the kinds of
you know
social identity cultural politics and
things like that so it's funny how the
the kind of the
the language or not the language but the
the conceptual structure
remains in place but it's it's construed
on a very different level
yeah
one of the theories that i've had about
the modern world or like let's say late
christianity and modernism is that it is
a kind of deincarnation
where you start to have ideal idealist
forms to manifest themselves and at the
same time you have this kind of gross
materialism but both of them seem to
kind of split you know and so at the
same time as you have people being all
these types of materials you have
theosophical ideas and all these
esotericists going on at the same time
whereas say maximus just offers this
beautiful capacity for synthesis you
know where where the highest
spiritual insights are not contradictory
to the phenomena in which they are
embodied they actually are they hold
them together
in a very similar way as the way that
platinus was mentioning it uh how you
quoted planets at the outset
yeah i think i think you could see this
as a kind of almost baroque
philosophical construction but you could
also say that you could also see it as a
kind of exegesis on some very basic
principles in the gospel so because
something like something as small and as
minute as a mustard seed right can
somehow be a symbol of the kingdom of
heaven
or that a human being a human person can
be the image of god suggests that
you know there's some sort of analogical
world here that contains symbolic uh
correspondences in other words that
there are particular
entities or things in the world but
they're not
unconnected or unrelated
so what i'd like to look at is you know
we see how say maximus draws these
analogies across different levels of
being and so he says things
like the you know the liturgy that we
encounter in the church is also
happening happening invisibly in you and
just as christ manifests himself the
eucharist you know christ manifests
himself in your heart he does these
plays where he's he's constantly moving
you know
across different levels of being to show
something which is not just an
interpretation of scripture or an
exposition of tradition but really ends
up being like we're talking about a
theory of reality itself
but what i'd like to because he does
talk about this liturgical space and
then the inner space um and so i'd like
you to talk a little bit about how
liturgy and asceticism shape the world
we live in you know how we embodying
these practices can help us make sense
of things that you know
that we don't usually attribute to the
sacred or to religion itself
sure
you had mentioned uh saint maximus's
work uh the mr goji and that's really
where so much of this kind of comes to
the fore
and i'll take advantage of the
opportunity to mention that uh the
patriotistics institute that i'm
directing these days is uh will be
holding a uh sponsoring a conference on
the mr goji in early april you can find
out more about it on our website we have
a great lineup of speakers and we have
more speakers that we'll be announcing
and we're hoping it'll be a very
exciting uh and important uh event so
sure liturgy and asceticism are two
things that most people might not
associate because
like so many other things they get
separated that liturgy is over here and
a cynicism is somehow somewhere else
perhaps even in tension with
liturgy so i mean in the mysticology
maximus describes this sort of movement
across
the three spaces or places of
of the church building which for him are
not northex naval sanctuary but nave
sanctuary and altar table so it's not
spaces but it's three
places i suppose around which liturgical
activity
unfolds so the movement for him though
is not simply a liturgical movement but
it's also
an ascetic movement now how does that
happen
that happens because
he takes the convenient number of three
three liturgical spaces
and he
correlates it to the three classic
stages of the spiritual life or
spiritual progress by which i mean
what evagrius would have called the
first stage
which means practical asceticism base
basically it's the keeping of the
commandments it's the sort of
entry-level kinds of aesthetic practices
you need to kind of get on the path and
start moving forward that would be the
the activity that takes place in the
nave is sort of asceticism let's say
basic asceticism then the sanctuary is
the space of contemplation
which is what you arrive at after
ascetic practice has somehow purified
consciousness
to the point where it's it's able to see
certain things that it couldn't see
earlier and then after that
mapped onto the
altar table and the eucharist is the
experience of union uh with god so the
liturgical movement now becomes
simultaneously a sort of ascetic and
contemplative uh
movement and people see this i think
rightly so
as an attempt to get to synthesize the
kind of dionysian tradition that maximus
inherits which is all about hierarchies
and liturgies and clerical orders and
religious services and these kinds of
things heavily ritualistic right
and heavily hierarchical
uh
that's the one element that he takes the
other element that uh max has sort of
inherited is the kind of the evagrian
spiritual tradition which is where the
stages of the three stages of spiritual
progress come from and he basically
fuses the two together he maps the one
onto the other uh so we have this kind
of interesting
convergence of let's say ecclesiology
church structures with the ascetic life
and the spiritual life and the mystical
life again things that are often subject
to a kind of disjunction
he has brought together in the place in
the church in the place of the liturgy
so i think some people might be familiar
with uh
the way he's mapped this same
ascetic trilogy or contemplative trilogy
onto the clerical orders of the church
because he says that the deacon
is the one who has purified his
consciousness through ascetical practice
and the priest he says is the one who
has illumined his mind with the
knowledge of creation that's the
division
beyond the surface of creation into the
intelligible structures of creation that
he calls uh the logi then the bishop he
says is the one who has perfected his
mind mind in in union with the trinity
so it's the three architectural spaces
of the church it's also the three
clerical orders that all coalesce in
this kind of contemplative uh uh moment
that's sort of the first step of all of
this and you see with maximus it's
always you're always playing what is it
three-dimensional chess or something or
right
do you see do you see because i see uh
something similar in the life of moses
by saying gregor nissa where he creates
this
uh ascetic
movement up the mountain you know into
the divine darkness but then when he
reaches into the divine darkness he
receives the plan for the tabernacle and
it's very fascinating because when he
receives the plan for the tabernacle
saint gregory describes the tabernacle
as a church and he says things you know
like the pillars of the tabernacle are
actually saints and he actually he has
the architectural pattern but then he
also has a human pattern where he he
maps on you know the different
participants of the church onto this
architectural structure
right that's a great point yeah i mean
uh that's actually definitely something
that should be brought into the way
the body and the temple correlate with
one another in uh the mystagogy look on
the one on the one hand this sort of
percolates up from christ in the in the
gospels
identifying his body with the temple
right so we have a very good precedent
for these kinds of analogies and you
have paul saying things like well the
body is your body is a temple of the
holy spirit
so that the later writers like maximize
develop this connection
in the way that they do is again it's
not it's not it's it might seem exotic
or unusual but it does have deep roots
in scripture i mean in these cases yeah
because we are the body as a church we
are the body of christ christ says that
his body
he lose his body being like the temple
and then our bodies are like temples the
analogy is already there in scripture
you know most of you know most of the
analogies that the fathers uh will
kind of
open up for us already there in the text
you know but they they they just help us
see them when we don't tend to see them
in the first place right
my impression is that
these writers took scripture
very very seriously i mean
literally too but not only literally but
they began there and they would read
things like the lord saying you know the
the mustard seed is is is a an image of
the kingdom or whatever and they would
say all right uh
we'll accept that is true
but now the question is under what
sort of conditions
might a statement like that be possible
to be true for that to work
what exactly has to be going on what
sort of a world does it need to be so
that a mustard seed can somehow have
this relationship with
this
sort of noetic reality called the
kingdom yeah when what you see is that
they think that way like their mind is
scripture it's amazing that all they
don't even explicitly sometimes make
parallels and you almost have to know
scripture yourself to realize that
they're connecting
different images together like and when
i read saint ephraim i get that so much
he doesn't tell you where he's getting
it but you almost have to know all
scripture to then see oh why he's saying
this because of this text in the psalms
and this text in scripture and he's
connecting them without telling me that
he's doing it
the other day with some students we're
reading origins prologue to the
commentary on the song of songs and
origin gives you every impression that
he knows the entire bible by heart
and can move between books and chapters
and verses i mean
faster than a database could
uh it's really just extraordinary to see
i mean someone with that i mean he was
rare it was a rare gift that he had but
it's extraordinary to see what can be
done when
one has that kind of awareness of the
text let's say that deep knowledge of it
but i wanted to go back to what we
started to say about the movement
through the temple space the liturgical
movement because if the goal of
everything is the vision of god which is
you know sort of unity with god
then you know whatever stands in the way
of that vision needs to be addressed
which is why so many of the church
fathers spend their time talking about
the passions
and other kinds of obstacles to the
vision not because they're fixated on
the negative aspects of human existence
but they want people to be well
so they can have this relationship with
god but if you're saddled with all kinds
of
we would call them things like
addictions and self-destructive
behaviors and so forth you're not going
to you know get very far down the road
toward the vision of god i mean there's
they'll quote
the the attitude
that blessed are the pure in heart
for they shall see god
so the vision of god then presupposes
purity of heart
so before we
sit around like fools talking about the
vision of god we need to talk about
right
what's what's obstructing that right
that vision
right how do we attain purity of heart
because that seems to be the proximate
goal that will get us to the ultimate
goal that we've been called to
uh arrive at
and this is i think a big part of of
maximus's approach to
it's not it's not all sort of beatific
visions there's a there's a labor that
has to take place there's a kind of
agony of of birth
uh
that consciousness has to
uh uh go through so our disordered
desires
he would say are kind of misinterpreting
the world to us
we're seeing the world through the
lenses or the filters of our disordered
desires of our passions as he would call
them these places in life where you've
gotten stuck or fixated on uh certain
things and the passions are interested
in pleasure not the truth so they'll
never get us to
the truth of what's out there what's in
the world so there has to be this
reformation in a sense of of uh
consciousness of awareness which they
call you know purification and other uh
kinds of uh terms like that and the way
that i think of it is through to a
helpful kind of phrase
in which we could say that every depth
has a surface
but not every surface has a depth
so that's why we need to attend to the
depth of things and not just to the
surfaces and i think this is a
particular challenge for us in our day
and age because we are obsessed with
surfaces fascinated with surfaces and uh
have a very hard time seeing past them
because all of reality has somehow been
absorbed into these surfaces and we take
the surface of the phenomenon as the
kind of ultimate object of uh a desire
but once you're able to
see through
once the surface of creation becomes
transparent
and i'm not just seeing what i'm
projecting onto it based on what my own
libido wants to do once i'm able to you
know see
through
the the transparent once the world
becomes transparent to me
then i i'm able to begin to see what
maximus calls these
intelligible principles or structures of
uh creation which is the presence of god
in the world it's the presence of god to
the special way that god makes himself
present to that world
and once the saints or the artist
grasps that or intuits in some way that
intelligible
structure
then he or she is able to
begin to transform the world on the
basis of
i mean that again that
principle of divinity that is kind of
informing the form that we see
and one of the things that's important
is
these patterns or these structures
they're not just the way we think of
scientific
rules or these these kind of abstract
patterns but they they call us right
they they are modes of being modes of
engaging in uh with the world
these are not the laws of nature
right and they're not even subatomic
elements they're they're they're
spiritual principles it's actually i
mean he calls them the logi
which is the plural for the logos
so it's the particular way that the
logos makes itself present to a thing
which is to say that the logos is not
present to
a rock in the same way that it's present
to a tree in the same way that it's
present to a human being
in the same way that it has a particular
mode of presence that is analogous to or
in proportion to
particular beings and to take it a step
further that mode of the logos is
presence to particular things
makes them what they are
it's that act of creation in a sense
right so so he calls them the loahi and
so through the created form
one has the possibility to to to see
the logos particularized by the uniform
logos made multiforme in the plurality
of the world and from there to proceed
to a more direct or immediate
understanding or relationship with the
logos itself
and ultimately the one of the secrets is
that these logi
if you pierce them enough they're
ultimately the logo the logos himself
that that ultimately behind the
multiplicity of the of the logi you find
the the one uh divine logos
right he says it's quite clearly that
you know the the many logie or the one
logos and the one logos is the mini logi
and yeah yeah
and so
so one of the things that surprises a
lot of modern christians that i've
noticed is they have this idea that
uh the incarnation is a reaction to the
fall right the incarnation is their god
you know we sinned we did all these bad
things god send god descends into the
world to take our to take our place all
of that type of language but in say
maximus and not just him but definitely
say maximus it appears very clearly that
the incarnation of the god man is not
only a reaction to the fall but it's
actually the very purpose of creation um
and so how can christ and the
incarnation
and the as the culmination of all things
help us make sense of our our purpose
our lives and our ultimate
destiny yeah i think that's exactly
right i mean without without reducing it
to a caricature
i think a western christian tradition
has concentrated on this narrative of
redemption in other words on the story
of the fall
and then the redemption of the fall
through christ and through his suffering
suffering crucifixion that seems to be
the kind of major narrative of so much
traditional western uh
christianity but from the perspective of
a writer like maximus the confessor and
i think you could say
more generally from the perspective of
the orthodox theological tradition that
story fall and redemption
is actually a smaller story within a
larger story sort of a smaller arc if
you will
that comes under this much larger arc
and the larger art is really it's not
fall and redemption but creation and
deification
so god creates the world what brings
beings into existence
for no other reason than to
ultimately unite them to himself
that's god's purpose in creation if you
read say basil's uh hexahon his
commentary on the opening verses of
genesis
he says well he comments on the verse
here when god saw that it was good
and then he asked well what exactly is
god looking at
that he thinks is so good and then he
has this beautiful sort of kind of
romantic
passage about is god seeing purple
mountains majesty and you know red
sunsets and you know these kinds he says
no he goes that's what we would think
might be beautiful right but that's not
what god is seeing at all god is seeing
he says the purpose for which he brought
things into being and that purpose is
union with himself in christ and that's
what he sees and that's what he says is
beautiful
so that's the divine plan for the
pre-eternal
divine plan is for creation and
deification
this is interrupted there's a
parenthesis that opens up a smaller arc
as i'm calling it of transgression and
redemption
and state maximum says that okay
uh uh the the the manner or the mode of
god's plan
had to change but the purpose never
changed the goal
always remained the same god never
took his eye in a sense off that aim
even though he had to get at it from a
slightly different way
because of the contingency let's say uh
of the fall so it was modified by human
free choice and sin but not done away
with in its sort of you know larger
former features so
and there's a way in which
we also he goes very far so max because
it's not just us we have we
people will might tend to accept that
humans are meant to be deified or meant
to participate in god but there's a
sense in his writings that it's it's
everything like all of creation somehow
at the level at which that's possible is
meant to be united and be you know be
part of the life of god participate in
the life of god
right i mean this is kind of a common
idea among the greek fathers that the
human person who was created last
in the biblical account is kind of the
the
sum or the summation of the creative
effort because it's in the human person
that creation retains consciousness that
matter attains consciousness in the
human person so the human person now
becomes the agent within creation
that has the ability to
uh recapitulate let's say within itself
uh the whole of the created order
this is i think really important for
people today because one of the problems
we have is this tendency in in scientism
to try to view
to view things and view meanings as
apart from man
but what same access offers and it's
actually an interesting solution to the
problem of emergency the problem of all
these phenomena is the notion that no
man is like a funnel where all of this
meaning gathers into and there's no way
to see
the meaning of the world and there's no
way to see the purposes of things in
creation without going first through man
and it that can really change a lot of
the way in which people
it brings us back to the more ancient
way of thinking we can understand what
aristotle
we can reconnect with some of the things
that aristotle talked about in terms of
final causes if we see them as
coming into man as this fulcrum which
joins the two the invisible and visible
together
yeah absolutely and i think we can give
this another twist because it's not
simply the human person that's the the
key or the linchpin here or one of the
one of the words he uses the workshop
and all of these things sort of are kind
of you know maybe it's an artisanal or
an artistic metaphor but it's the human
person in christ
because we
failed to
attain the goal that was established for
our nature
which is why christ came and
did it for us in a sense or uh and
showed us the way and made that way
available to us so it's not just a human
thing it's a human divine kind of work
um
you know
you hear you hear lots of words today
like
justice or equality or i don't know
truth or righteousness or whatever they
are
and they're largely detached from any
kind of context and of course we that we
proclaim them very loudly and we demand
that demand them and insist on them but
i think you know in in the in the
christian tradition not just the
orthodox tradition now but i think in
the whole christian tradition
those words don't exist not simply apart
from human beings they don't exist upon
i mean they don't make sense apart from
christ
in other words the whole tradition is
this personalist tradition there are no
abstract categories out there like
justice or righteousness or uh uh
equality or identity or you know you
name it and all of these things have
their locus
in this redeemed
humanity uh that we find in christ so
it's his truth it's his justice it's his
righteousness and you know i think a lot
of this kind of language this sort of
this fragmentation of the language has
crept into many christian traditions but
i think we adopted at our own peril
because it's to forget this larger
context in which those words originally
were defined in a sense and and made
sense
yeah we see it in the in the modern
attempt to demyth d mythologize the
scripture and to try abstract these
moral principles
out of the narrative but uh we can see
where that leads you know we can see in
the in the 20th century and the 19th
20th century with the revolutions and
all these
this chaos we can see where to remove it
from the narrative from the ritual from
this participation you know it it uh it
leads us into scary places
right because that first you abstract
the categories of the concepts
then you impose them on societies or
communities and uh you know as you said
we we there are more than enough
examples just from our own recent
history to
to illustrate what can go wrong so
exactly
so one of the things i mentioned at the
outset is that we both have uh a love
for art a liturgical art but art in
general culture
and how it is that christians can
connect to culture and this is really
something that i'm seeing
that many artists especially christians
artists today they really struggle at
how to position themselves in the world
and one of the the images that you bring
about in your writing which i found very
beautiful
is you talk about the gifts that is the
you know when people bring the gifts
into um into the liturgy to for the
bread and the wine to become the
eucharist you mentioned that it's not
just about giving up the raw materials
but it's also bringing up
you know human activity because these
things have already been transformed um
and so you get a sense in which it is
this art which is also being brought to
then
be offered back to us as the blood and
body of christ
but there's also another
important thread in the ascetic
tradition of the church you know we see
it in hezikazim
is the suspicion towards imagination
and i've seen many artists who kind of
approach orthodoxy become completely
bewildered when they read the philocalia
or they read these ascetic writings and
there's the they're completely strong
they struggle on what to do because they
don't understand the relationship
between human making and this also
suspicion of imagination and so um one
of the things that i was surprised to
men to notice is i saw your name in the
credits for
a recent movie a hidden life
and uh and so i thought oh interesting
to see that you have some connection
with this project which many people have
seen as um
as being a powerful example of a
christian story being told and so
you know what advice do you have for
artists for musicians architects you
know uh but also writers filmmakers
people who want to create culture today
whether sacred art or secular art and
how is it that they can do this as
christians or even as secular people who
want to act in truth and make beautiful
things
yeah i think i think i hear two sort of
broad questions there and the first
thing you started to talk about was
the role of
art i suppose or what can artists take
from let's say the liturgical experience
or the life of the church and i think
you mentioned the gifts that's why i say
this
and it's interesting uh i mean one issue
is that
under under pressure from a certain
form of scholarship we have to say we
insist on this idea that well the
eucharist is a meal
and anything that detracts from a kind
of you know
dinner-like atmosphere is somehow wrong
or bad now obviously it's a meal
historically it began as a meal but we
always want to avoid reductionism right
so if you think about the eucharist i
mean what happens
you know maximus describes this
liturgical movement through the church
that climaxes on the altar table with
the consecration of the eucharist which
he covers in silence by the way he
doesn't comment on that particular
moment but we don't offer
wheat
and grapes
alone
we offer bread and wine which means what
that we take the gifts
that the creator has given us
and with the the the power of technology
and mind that the creator has also given
us we transformed those gifts into
something more than what they were and
again that rests on the ability
for the mind to see okay what what
qualities in here within this wheat and
within these grapes that that can be
transformed or they can bring out
something even greater about them
and we offer that back and as you know
uh
we we offer that and we say thine own of
the i don't know your own of your own
your own gifts
from your own gifts this is what we
offer back to you we have nothing else
to give god everything we have
we've received from him but we don't
just say okay are we gifting the same
gift you gave us we express our
gratitude by transforming it
and offering it back in this remarkable
truly remarkable way and this
liturgical moment let's say this
liturgical act i think becomes
paradigmatic or should be paradigmatic
for
all human activity so i mean this means
that something like work in science or
in society should be based on wisdom and
reason and not on another kind of a
calculus or the organization of the the
social world it should be justice and
compassion not expedience or profit or
something like that and for me the
examples that come readily to mind are
how this kind of paradigm
inspires human art and human artists to
sort of unearth
the
spiritual potentials just like what was
in the
wheat and what was in the grapes there
are spiritual potentials within all
matter within marble within wood within
pigments within all kinds of things to
unearth those principles and then to
sort of
show them forth
in the place of the church in monumental
art and uh uh architecture so that's
that's the work of the artist at least
as it's understood within uh the the the
futuristic tradition in the orthodox
tradition to enable in other words i
think it's dimitri stanley stanley who
talks about this and he speaks about it
very beautifully he says the the the
inside and the art of the artist the
techne
of the artist is that thing
that practice which enables the elements
of creation to join in the magnificent
chant of the liturgy
right they're voiceless until we give
them that voice that they have there's
an inner potential that we bring out and
then we and that enters into the space
of the church where everything is
transformed
there's no there are no raw materials
lying around in the church everything is
polished and carved and worked and
drilled and painted and right it's this
it represents a transfer it represents
an icon in the sense
of of the whole universe in a state of
transformation
there are two images that come to me
right away is
in reading this description of the gifts
being brought up first of all the first
thing that comes to me is the parable of
the talents which i would never would
have connected to this but seems to
really uh
join into this image of bringing you
know god giving us things and then us
having to
make it fruitful and then bring it back
and the other is the the new jerusalem
itself there's an amazing uh little
description of the new jerusalem where
it says that the glories of all the
nations are gathered into
the holy city into the new jerusalem so
this idea that all these positive things
of what of human activity are gathered
into this this final image of the of the
holy city
well the other idea there though is that
is that it's not a return to a garden
but there's a movement from garden from
a quote natural state to what to this
urban fabric yeah to this magnificent
human artifact in a sense it's not a
human artifact but the the image that's
used is not of a forest or a grove or
garden but it's it's it's a it's of a
built
environment right a structure an
architecture and so
sorry yes that's what i wanted because
that's the hardest part for artists is
the aesthetic part
is this the aesthetic part of the
assembly well the part the part where
you read how because we know like let's
say i let's say i create things and i
know that there's a buffer there's a
place
like between
any and the tradition and and the making
which would be something like
imagination
and and i know that i use my imagination
to create things and so it's hard for us
when we read the texts that are so
suspicious of imagination to know how is
it to live like how how can we join
these two things together
right you know uh yeah that's right so
that's a big there's a lot of people
i've heard from others that
talked about this the other day i
watched with some of my students
tarkovsky's uh andre rubler
anyone who hasn't seen it you know was
encouraged to run out and do so but it's
largely about i mean obviously tarkovsky
has projected his own artistic struggles
into the figure of andre rublov who
despite the fact that it's a three-hour
movie about an iconographer he never
picks up a paintbrush right because the
problem that rupalev is facing which is
the problem tarkovsky was facing is how
can one be an artist how can one create
or be creative in a world
torn apart by violence and hatred and
suffering under oppression
so so there's that it's sort of like
that famous statement by teodoradorno
that
poetry after
auschwitz is barbaric which actually
adorno retracted at some later part but
there is a question about
just
how does one proceed to be artistic or
creative in a world uh uh such as ours
but i think the precondition to go back
to what i said a moment ago the
precondition for artistic uh uh uh
vision or creativity has to begin in
that place of asceticism in a sense
a kind of self-denial you know there's
there's a
a great passage from one of
tchaikovsky's uh journals from the from
the 70s and he says extraordinary things
about artistic talent because he was
nothing if not a great artist and he
says that talent is not so much a gift
from god it's really it's it's a cross
that the artist is doomed to carry
right because there is a kind of you
look at there's a demonism
in art right i mean
great writers and alcoholism and all
these other cliches that we have or you
know rock stars and the stuff that the
trouble they get into and whatnot i mean
there's something about
art that can be
that could be dangerous let's say or or
you know uh you pay for it with your
soul deals with the devil think of all
of the popular cliches and stuff right
so he says it's it's a cross to be
carried which i think is that that
uh
ascetic moment where whatever we have
like st maximum says everything needs a
cross
because it's either too much or too
little nothing is quite right and it
needs to be
crucified in a sense is that great
uh it's a buddhist once said that i like
the cross
because it crosses out the eye
right
so you know the the you know iris
murdoch talks about the unselving
of the artist that has to take but she
uses the image of marcias who's played
by apollo which again is sort of the
price that the uh uh
artist uh uh has to pay or should pay
and since you mentioned uh a hidden life
i think one of my favorite scenes in the
whole film is where the main character
franz jaegersteiner is in his church
which is being uh the wall paintings of
which are being uh refurbished i suppose
by an artist and jager center is sort of
the church warden so they spend time
together and they're talking and the
artist is this very interesting uh
figure he's a voice for somebody or
something
and uh he's uh he's almost like
theophone by the way in andre rubler
because he's a little
not exactly sarcastic but maybe a touch
cynical or world weary whatever but he
says at one point he says
he's talking about revolt the role of
the artist
the role of the the iconographer in a
way and he says at one point you know
how can i how can i be painting these
images he says how can i paint
what i haven't lived
and then at the end it becomes a
voiceover it's the same artist speaking
and malik
plays the voice as a voiceover as oh
this beautiful landscape with a setting
sun and the last thing he says is one
day
i hope to paint
a true christ
which to me is just
that was worth the price of admission
alone
so
it's like i have a friend he's a he's a
painter he's a priest in california he's
a fantastic uh painter he actually
painted the portrait of me that you see
on the inside flap of the art of seeing
book
i was camera shy at the time so i had a
portrait commission but he didn't he did
it as a as a as a favor as a expression
of his friendship but he said once i
asked him what i said what is art
right
he said he goes art he said without even
thinking art is the search for an
archetype
which is sort of what
the paper in hidden life is saying
right one day i hope to paint a true
christ and we have this theology in the
church of image and likeness and the ima
it's
kind of thing where the image bears uh a
resemblance to
or to the to the
archetype to the source but the image
longs for the source it yearns for the
source it's not it's not a visual thing
only
it's a relationship of desire that's
created because the image that
emerges from the archetype
longs for reunion uh with its source
that's why i say that art is this sort
of search for an archetype
um
i mean we're still having to imagination
yet but we're getting there okay
do you what do you think i mean i i
think that what you're saying is very
powerful i
on the one hand i see it
on the other hand i have these immense
contradictions you know because
i in my own experience let's say like in
my own experience i've i've found the
strange moment where
you know
that the works that say i'm making icons
i'm making icons for churches i'm making
icons for people and the the works which
are objectively
better
sometimes and that when people look at
them they'll say crazy things like you
know oh this the holy spirit you know
did something and i know that
that when i made that
i was not like i was not there like i
was in a massive fight with my wife or i
was completely off the off off off the
off the road and then the opposite
sometimes isn't necessarily true like
those moments where you know i'm really
rigorous with my daily prayers and i'm
doing the jesus prayer i'm doing that
won't necessarily produce
better better icons and so i it's like i
struggle because i i can see what you're
saying in the ideal but in the practice
it seems like there's a strangeness
about our path which doesn't necessarily
i sometimes i i see it almost as
in a way it is kind of grace in the
sense that just like you know a priest
can
let's say the the liturgy is efficient
no matter what the priest is going
through and so sometimes i get the
feeling that maybe that's what's going
on because
i can't account let's say for the
quality of my work in my spiritual life
that's a very strong confession i'm
making but it's true
oh i mean
there are different moments right i mean
you're right i'm i'm talking about the
ideal because that's sort of like the
point of light that i'm gesturing toward
that's the goal that's the aim that's
the the idea without ideals without
these things where would we be
um but that's not all there is i mean
you know that's the thing
every day in the life of a married
couple over 50 years was like just an
ongoing honeymoon right i mean if it was
that by the way it would mean they never
grew in their relationship either
they say oh
it's not like it wasn't when first got
married well thank god for that right
because you're not supposed to be
standing still so i mean what you're
describing is so sort of somewhere else
on the map it gets back to the the
struggle
it gets back to this kind of you know
burdensome sort of
mixed
situation that we're in that paul
describes you know in terms of the
things that i want to do i don't do and
the things that
uh uh well you know how the rest goes
yeah um
sort of at st maximus describes this as
we're in this kind of middle state right
now
between
creation and then
deification and you know there's this
being
and then there's uh well-being and then
there's eternal well-being we're in this
middle place where we're trying to be
well
we're trying to live properly but of
course no i mean it's like the parable
of the wheat and the tears i mean
everything is mixed together in this
life and saint paul says if there's
another law
at work in my members
that's hostile to god that doesn't want
god right that doesn't mean that that's
all there is to you just because you're
having a bad day doesn't mean god can't
work through you i'll spare you the
uh injurious analogy of of
of god speaking through the ass in the
old testament
i'll take it that's okay i'm fine with
that oh i can do better you're a nice
guy i'll do better than that it's even
even the high priest spoke prophecy that
that year
not knowing what he was saying but
because of his office right so
who can i mean who can who can
unfold all of these mysteries of life i
mean they're
just the complexities of what we're
called to sort of try to work through
but what is your advice for the proper
use of imagination this is the hardest
one i kept the hardest for the last for
the ending well i i think i think
there's a lot of confusion about this
word in the first place and i think when
most of us hear that word and use that
word we're probably conditioned by
i don't know the roman the romantic
period
people like coleridge and what they have
to say about the power of the
imagination
it's also coupled with this kind of
particularly modern understanding of the
artist as a sort of isolated creative
genius so all of those things get you
know mixed up with all of this
and in english
imagination isn't a nice sounding word
so this image is a nice word then
there's imagination and we're always
talking about reimagining things and
that's always a good thing or whatever
but in funny in it so it's innocuous
imagine image imagination in greek
though the word for image is icon or
igor right in the modern version but
imagination in greek is fandasia
where we get our english word fantasy
from
so we're not we're not even in the same
ballpark anymore
so imagination you know that sounds good
right that sounds nice but
fantasy that's
already a different kind of
idea or uh experience and i've heard
many
uh modern day church artists whether
they're iconographers
or church musicians or church architects
and they're all saying look we don't
want to be condemned to repeating the
prototypes of the past
right we we are creative artists we have
our talents we have our gifts and we
want to do our own thing right that's
what that's what people a long time ago
did right when where did those
prototypes come from somebody conjured
those things up so why can't we do the
same i've heard that i've heard this
many many times i'll come back to this
but before i do i want to lay out a
couple of things that i think are
critical in this conversation just play
two points basically
everybody knows the story of jacob's
dream
where the poor guy goes to sleep with a
stone for a pillow and then has this
uh
dream of the heavenly ladder
now when he wakes up
what does jacob do
the bible says he raises the stone and
he anoints it
he builds an altar he basically he
builds an altar so the vision that he
had which is not a product of his
fantasy or imagination or because he was
sleeping on a rock or you know
his
food he had for dinner is somehow
influencing it no we understand it to be
a revelation that's given to him so
the the the the divine revelation that
he receives somehow spontaneously
results in the creation of sacred space
that's that's the kind of the minor
example that i have the major example
that everybody knows
is and it's the best one is moses's
entry into the dark cloud where he sees
what the archetype you mentioned it
earlier of the celestial uh tabernacle
this is revealed to him and god gives
him specific directions about how to
construct it and on what days and what
materials to use and
an entire plan a blueprint for
reproducing in
in matter
right this immaterial reality right for
this
material image of the immaterial and
invisible celestial uh tabernacle so we
have this heavenly archetype or this
heavenly form that now becomes reflected
and
built
in the represented in the
uh material world now most people if
they heard that sentence alone they
would say oh he must be talking about
plato
it sounds like there are forms up there
and then they sort of have their
material shadows
down in the world where leave it where
we live right but
moses lived about what is it a thousand
years before plato right so so this is
why you have that great saying by
the second century philosopher rumenius
who gets it from an earlier alexandrian
hellenistic jewish thinker aristotle and
he says well he says
don't get too excited about plato he
said after all what is plato
if not moses speaking attic greek yeah
so so this is not the platonic view of
the world this is the priestly view of
the world
right and we we
deny ourselves as tremendous resource if
we dismiss it as so much uh platonism so
the idea i think
in other words any artist who is
who thinks that art is about putting
across an idea or propagating a personal
thought or some sort of prayer i mean
i would ask that person to think about
these biblical passages and what they've
meant to the church
right and that that maybe maybe
iconography is not reducible to art in
the modern sense and maybe the making of
icons is not simply some private
creative thing that i do or that you do
to sort of satisfy some creative impulse
now having said all of that i don't want
to deny a place for the imagination but
it has to be
tempered it has to be disciplined it has
to be educated it has to be part of this
larger liturgical movement that uh we've
been talking about uh here which is why
nearly all so many iconographers in the
church are are saints
i mean andre ruble was recently yeah
so
yeah no i think i think that your
insight is is is right and i the way
that i kind of see it is that there's a
there's a hierarchy to say it that way
that is there's a way in which you have
like an imac you can imagine something
like you have uh you know the life of
the saint and then you have the
ideography
and then a little bit lower down on that
ladder you'll have something like
legends of about these saints that are
yeah you know they end up being a little
more fantastical you know and so there's
a sense in which we don't we kind of
look at these legends we find them fun
and amusing or we we find them
uh interesting to help us kind of see a
bit further but then we also have higher
versions of these stories and you see it
it almost seems like you see that even
in apocryphal literature right where we
have scripture and then we have certain
apocrypha which are pretty
that's a pretty kosher in a way and then
you it kind of comes down into all these
more and more fantastical versions of
apocrypha but even in those fantastical
ones we might have some little glimpse
there's a little seed that will be
carried and will be kind of kept in the
tradition um that's at least the way
that i i try to uh to see it um and so
the what it does is it leaves a
possibility for something like a hidden
life which is obviously not a liturgical
work
it's not it's not liturgical art but it
it connects through little seeds to
something that we can find at the let's
say at higher levels of of of
participation in the liturgy for example
i know that if that layout makes sense
to you
yeah there's definitely to use your word
there's definitely sort of a if you want
a hierarchy of
forms let's say
uh everything from you know things
revealed in scripture to
apocryphal stories some of them have
greater value than others and so forth
so but i i think the thing to also say
is that often these very seemingly naive
kinds of stories contain you know
tremendous wisdom
right there's a one of my former
colleagues he's since proposed god mr
soul was an authority on the uh gospel
of luke
and uh francois bovan he was a swiss uh
scholar of the new testament and his
work was remarkable because i mean he
knew the gospel of luke better than most
people
and he was also interested in these
apocryphal traditions that that were
based on the gospel of luke and he he
saw these
not as
aberrations let's say or departures from
the canonical narrative but simply
different forms of exegesis because if
you really
thought about what the story was saying
it wasn't some
hokey kind of you know i don't know
uh aesop's fable or i don't know what i
mean something will be sounds famous
this is really just another way of
unfolding
uh the the the biblical account by
either by expanding it or by right so it
doesn't always work because there are
some apocryphal texts that the church
has you know condemned or dismissed or
whatever but others it's been happy to
make use of so yeah we sometimes don't
think there's christian would we midrash
you know but i think definitely there is
which is this interpretation through
storytelling
right we don't tell you the meaning we
create
we we expand parts of the story that are
invisible or that are in between
other facts and by expanding those you
can actually see the connection that
exists between the different aspects of
the original story more than you could
before and it seems like that's
definitely something which exists in in
christianity there's there's amazing
legends in jacques varajin's golden
legend you know this legend of the cross
which
describes how the cross was you know
taken and then it became
the rod of moses not across the tree in
the in the garden became the rod of
moses and all these different things
until it then becomes the cross of
christ and you think okay that's wild
and crazy
exactly but you think it's crazy but
then if you look at how the exegesis is
like how the the fathers will interpret
the meaning of the cross you'll see that
no it's actually doing in a narrative
way what the fathers would do in a more
just in a more descriptive way which is
you know there is a connection between
the rod of moses his staff the cross and
the tree uh and so you can do that in a
manner that that that brings it all
together in a story so yeah
right i mean there's a romano melodious
very famous sixth century liturgical uh
poet has a poem on the crucifixion
and he talks about the cross being
planted on golgotha and the roots of
this because the word in the word for
wood in greek siloam is the same word
for a tree
so when you say the cross was planted
you're saying this tree was planted just
the wood in other words was planted the
wood of the cross the tree and the roots
of the thing of the cross penetrate deep
into the earth and they puncture the
body of death
so it's sort of like the world's tree in
a way yeah and whether or not romanos
knew about that i have no idea but
the idea presented itself to his mind
and there it is in that in that konjac
in that poem so
it's wonderful well we've been going for
much longer than i'd planned because
this is just a great conversation but i
think i think that we've given people
quite enough to to think about uh and to
explore uh and so i i encourage
everybody to to look into the conference
which is happening this spring if you
can go the people that are going to be
there are really the summits i've
mentioned many of them on this channel
before and so i think it would really
it would be a good place for a lot of
the people watching these videos to uh
to learn more about zimax and how it
connects to the world today and so
father maxwell thank you for your time
thank you for for taking this time with
me i really appreciate it
it was it was a lot of fun
and maybe we'll do it again i hope so
that would be great
thank you
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your
usual podcast platform but we also have
a website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have a clips channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support